dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here some
papers come with an intense media
campaign and a lot of nice videos and
some other amazing papers are at the
risk of slipping under the radar because
of the lack of such a media presence
this new work from deep mind is indeed
absolutely amazing you'll see in a
moment why and is not really talked
about so in this video let's try to
reward such a work in many episodes you
get ice cream for your eyes but today
you get ice cream for your mind
buckle up in the last few years we have
seen deep minds a I defeat the best goal
players in the world and after open a
eyes venture in the game of dota 2 deep
mind embarked on a journey to defeat pro
players in Starcraft 2 a real-time
strategy game this is a game that
requires a great deal of mechanical
skill split-second decision-making and
we have imperfect information as we only
see what our units can see a nightmare
situation for any AI you see some
footage of its previous games here on
the screen and in my opinion people seem
to pay too much attention to how good a
given algorithm performs and too little
to how general it is let me explain deep
mind has developed a new technique that
tries to rely more on its predictions of
the future and generalizes to many many
more games than previous techniques this
includes alpha zero a previous technique
also from them that was able to play go
chess and Japanese chess or shogi as
well and beat any human player at these
games confidently this new method is so
general that it does as well as alpha
zero at these games however it can also
play a wide variety of Atari games as
well and that is the key here writing an
algorithm that plays chess well has been
a possibility for decades for instance
if you wish to know more make sure to
check out stockfish which is an
incredible open source project and a
very potent algorithm however stockfish
cannot play anything else whenever we
look at a new game we have to derive a
new algorithm that solves it not so much
with these learning methods that can
generalize to a wide
variety of games this is why I would
like to argue that the generalization
capability of these AIS is just as
important as their performance in other
words if there was a narrow algorithm
that is the best possible chess
algorithm that ever existed or the
somewhat below world champion level AI
that can play any game we can possibly
imagine I would take the ladder in a
heartbeat now speaking about
generalization let's see how well it
does at these Atari games shall we
after 30 minutes of time on each game it
significantly outperforms humans on
nearly all of these games the
percentages show you here what kind of
out performance we are talking about in
many cases the algorithm outperforms us
several times and up to several hundred
times absolutely incredible as you see
it has a more than formidable score on
almost all of these games and therefore
it generalizes quite well I'll tell you
in a moment about the games it falters
at but for now let's compare it to three
other competing algorithms you see one
ball number per row which always
highlights the best performing algorithm
for your convenience the new technique
beats the others on about 66% of the
games including the recurrent experience
replay technique in short r2d2 yes this
is another one of those crazy paper
names and even when it falls short
it is typically very close as a
reference humans triumphed on less than
10% of the games we still have a big fat
zero on pitfall and the montezuma's
revenge games so why is that well these
games require long-term planning which
is one of the most difficult cases for
reinforcement learning algorithms in an
earlier episode we discussed how we can
infuse an AI agent with curiosity to go
out there and explore some more with
success however note that these
algorithms are more narrow than the one
we've been talking about today so there
is still plenty of work to be done but I
hope you see that this is incredibly
nimble progress on AI research Bravo
deep mind
what a time to be alive this episode has
been supported by Linode Linode is the
world's largest independent cloud
computing provider they offer affordable
GPU instances featuring the Quadro r-tx
6000 which is tailor-made for AI
scientific computing and computer
graphics projects exactly the kind of
works you see here in this series if you
feel inspired by these works and you
wish to run your own experiments or
deploy your already existing works
through a simple and reliable hosting
service make sure to join over 800,000
other happy customers and choose Linode
to spin up your own GPU instance and
receive a $20 free credit visit
linda.com slash papers or click the link
in the description and use the promo
code papers 20 during signup give it a
try today our thanks to Lee node for
supporting the series and helping us
make better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time